se a fx igual a menos 1 entre x menos 1
al cuadrado selecciona la opción
correcta de los límites unilaterales de
f en x igual a 1 y como podemos ver
tenemos un montón de opciones donde nos
estamos aproximando a x por el lado
derecho y nos estamos aproximando a x
por el lado izquierdo y estamos tratando
de encontrar si llegamos al infinito en
cualquiera de ellos y si llegamos al
infinito vamos hacia el infinito
positivo o vamos hacia el infinito
negativo y hay un par de formas de
abordarlo la más fácil es considerar
cada uno de estos por separado entonces
pensemos por un lado en el límite de fx
cuando x tiende a 1 por la derecha y por
otra parte pensemos en el límite de fx
cuando x tiende a 1 por la izquierda así
que voy a hacer una tabla y vamos a
probar algunos valores cuando nos
aproximamos a uno de los diferentes
lados así que por aquí voy a tener la
equis y por acá me voy a fijar en
fx y haré lo mismo para este otro límite
entonces por acá vamos a tener la equis
y por acá
fx ahora si nos aproximamos a uno por el
lado derecho eso quiere decir que
estaría aproximando me a uno por valores
más grandes que él así que podemos
probar no sé con 1.1 podemos probar con
1.01 y ahora veamos cuánto vale
efe de 1.1 y solamente que poner en
lugar de x 1.1 entonces me quedarían
menos 1 entre 1.1 menos 1 esto a su vez
elevado al cuadrado
entonces observa que el denominador va a
ser igual o simplemente 0.1 elevado al
cuadrado y bueno 0.1 elevado al cuadrado
eso va a ser lo mismo que 0.01 y si
divido menos uno entre 0.0 uno bueno eso
simplemente nos va a dar menos 100 ahora
vamos a ver cuánto vale f
cuando x es igual a 1.01 y bueno
siguiendo la misma lógica
1 entre 1.0 1 - 1 esto elevado al
cuadrado bien pero en este caso el
denominador va a ser 0.01 elevado al
cuadrado que es lo mismo que 0.0001 un
10 milésima y así que menos 1 entre un
10.000 es simón va a ser igual a menos
10.000 y ahora observa que esto parece
que cuando nos acercamos a uno por la
derecha me estoy acercando y acercando y
acercando a uno por valores mayores que
él y lo que estoy obteniendo es un
límite hacia infinito negativo entonces
parece que esto va a ser igual a menos
infinito y ahora podemos hacer lo mismo
del lado derecho podría tomarme x igual
a 0.9 y podría tomar me a x igual a 0.99
ahora 0.9 en realidad también me va a
dar menos 100 ya que en 0.9 menos 1 va a
ser menos 0.1 pero cuando lo elevamos al
cuadrado el negativo se va y me va a dar
exactamente igual qué
0.01 que lo que teníamos a la izquierda
y luego si divido menos uno entre eso me
va a dar menos 100 y si no siguieron los
cálculos lo haré una vez más para que lo
vean claramente pero ahora lo voy a
hacer con x igual a 0.99 esto va a ser
igual a menos uno más sobre y ahora
estoy haciendo a x igual a 0.99 así que
me estoy acercando más a 1 me estoy
aproximando uno por el lado izquierdo y
me va a quedar en la parte de abajo en
el denominador 0.99 menos 1 esto elevado
al cuadrado
ahora 0.99 menos 1 va a ser lo mismo que
un centésimo negativo entonces esto de
aquí va a ser igual a 0.01 negativo esto
elevado al cuadrado pero cuando él le
ven al cuadrado negativo se va a ir y me
voy a quedar simplemente con un
diezmilésimos entonces esto va a ser
igual
aamer 0.0001 y observa que es lo mismo
que teníamos en el lado izquierdo cuando
hacemos la división de menos 1 entre ese
diezmilésimos vamos a obtener menos
diez mil así que en cualquier caso sin
importar desde qué dirección se
aproximamos nos estamos aproximando en
ambos casos a menos infinito
entonces se observa las opciones la
opción correcta es esta opción de aquí
bien ahora hay otras maneras en que
podremos abordar este mismo problema
otra de ellas sería observar la
estructura de esta expresión que tengo
aquí y pensar qué es lo que está pasando
si observas el numerador es una
constante entonces claramente va a ser
positivo y aunque tenemos este signo
negativo vamos a ignorarlo por un
momento y pensemos en el signo del
numerador el cual va a ser siempre
positivo y aquí abajo
estamos tomando a x menos 1 si x es
igual a 1 esto se vuelve 0 y toda la
expresión se vuelve indefinida pero como
nos aproximamos a 1 entonces x menos 1
podría ser positivo o negativo de hecho
lo vimos justo aquí en estas tablas pero
luego lo vamos a elevar al cuadrado y
esto va a volverse positivo también
entonces el denominador va a ser
positivo también para cualquier equis
diferente de uno claro y ahora si
tenemos a un número positivo dividido
entre otro número positivo vamos a tener
algo positivo y luego por ese signo
negativo que tenemos en un principio
toda esta cosa nos va a dar algo
negativo y de nuevo para x diferente de
uno y de eso podrían deducir que si
observamos las opciones entonces
solamente podemos ir a menos infinito en
realidad no hay manera de obtener
valores positivos para esta función